elle aussi fait partie de notre art de
vivre la musique classique un peu moins
classique justement quand elle s'invite
dans le train un moment de grâce dont on
pu profiter il y a quelques jours les
passagers d'un TER entre tour et Paris à
côté d'eux des musiciens et chanteurs de
l'ensemble j mi l'opération était
organisée par la SNCF la région Centre
valde Loire et le festival concert
d'automne Clémence d'os qui a eu la
chance d'y assister regardez et écoutez
surtout partition sur les tablettes
instruments sur les sièges des passagers
pas si ordinaires voyagent à bord de ce
train réi Express mesdames et messieurs
bonjour rebonjour à ceux qu'on a pas vu
on va faire un petit moment musical donc
là on va vous janter le dernier du haut
dans l'orpéo de mon
[Musique]
ver
pr en quelques notes l'ensembleie nous
transporte dans l'Italie baroque du 17e
siècle l'acoustique du wagon se prête
étonnamment au jeu pour un rendu
harmonieux et théâtral la musique
italienne au 17e siècle a beaucoup
inspiré tous les compositeurs de
chansons d'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
simples des rappeurs ou bien même de la
musique populaire des années 80 qu'on
aime tellement avec Michael Jackson tout
ça c'est repris énormément sur les mêmes
principes harmoniques et mélodiques de
la musique italienne 17e
[Musique]
siècle
derrière cette prestation une mise en
avant des concerts d'automne la démarche
du festival est celle de faire venir la
culture et notamment la musique
classique jusqu'au citoyens ça permet de
de faire découvrir cette ce style
musical cette cet univers artistique à
des personnes qui peut-être n'avaient
pas prévu de venir au festival des
concerts d'automne à
tour prochaine arrêt pour ridie la ville
de tour la trou est à retrouver sur les
planches du grand théâtre le 14
[Musique]
octobre